On regarde aujourd'hui ce nouveau Samsung
Galaxy Note 8 qui est présenté en avant-première
à l'IFA.
C'est un produit qui est très sympa.
En terme de taille je ne sais pas si on se
rend bien compte si on compare la taille avec
un iPhone 7 forcément la gamme Note c'est
beaucoup plus grand.
Côté écran vous avez un écran Infinity
6,3 pouces QuadHD+ SuperAmoled.
C'est vraiment un écran vraiment confortable,
très pratique.
C'est vraiment à mon sens l'un des plus beaux
écrans du moment avec le LG V30 qui m'a carrément
bluffé, pour moi celui-ci c'est un produit
qui est vraiment très très sympa, très
agréable à regarder.
Le bord à bord c'est toujours top.
Un produit qui est quand même assez fin.
Bord à bord.
C'est vrai qu'on voit très bien l'aspect
bord à bord qui est sympa.
Vous avez deux capteurs à l'arrière.
Un grand angle en 12Mpx et un téléobjectif
en 12Mpx.
Ils vous permettent de jouer sur la profondeur
de champ lorsque vous faites des photos.
C'est un produit qui se déverrouille à l'arrière
ici.
Ce qu'on peut regretter c'est l'inconfort
car lorsque vous allez chercher à le déverrouiller
ici, vous risquez de poser votre doigt sur
la caméra et de la salir.
C'est le point négatif de ce produit.
Vous avez ici votre slot pour mettre votre
carte SIM et pour rajouter votre carte micro-SD.
Vous pouvez monter jusqu'à 256Go en mémoire.
Ce qui vous permet d'avoir beaucoup de stockage.
Donc c'est plutôt sympa.Il y évidemment
un bouton Bixby que vous trouvez ici.
Les boutons de volume, le bouton pour l'allumer.
Vous avez votre prise jack.
Il se charge en USB-C.
C'est un produit qui est extrêmement sympa.
Avec vous avez le S-Pen qui est ici.
Alors forcément ici tout est attaché donc
il faut tirer un petit peu mais c'est un produit
qui se prend très bien en main.
C'est très agréable de le prendre pour dessiner.
Il est très léger, plutôt compact.
Il a beaucoup de points positifs.
Le Galaxy Note 8 est résistant à la poussière
et à l'eau avec une certification IP68.
On retrouve également ici, je ne sais pas
si vous le voyez bien, la caméra de selfie
qui vous permettra d'avoir une reconnaissance
faciale, une reconnaissance de l'iris aussi
pour le déverrouiller.
Vous pouvez le déverrouiller avec la reconnaissance
faciale, reconnaissance de l'iris, avec le
capteur d'empreinte digitale derrière.
Vous pouvez saisir un code et vous pouvez
aussi faire le dessin.
Je ne me souviens plus comment ça s'appelle
mais on le retrouve sur les Samsung.
En dimension c'est un produit qui mesure 162,5
x 74,8 et une épaisseur de 8,6 millimètres.
A l'avant ce que l'on peut regretter sur un
produit comme celui-là, comme sur tous les
smartphones en ce moment, vous avez uniquement
un appareil photo de 8Mpx.
Lorsque vous voulez faire du livestream sur
Youtube, que vous voulez simplement vous filmer
avec un moniteur pour pouvoir vous regarder,
vous n'avez pas une qualité optimale.
C'est à mon sens ce que l'on peut regretter
sur tous les smartphones actuels.
Si on compare par exemple avec le LGV30 qui
va sortir au mois de novembre, vous avez une
caméra 5Mpx à l'avant et c'est vraiment
dommage.
Quand est-ce que les constructeurs vont enfin
nous ajouter des excellentes caméras sur
le devant ? Car la plupart des utilisateurs
se filment directement et ont besoin d'un
moniteur pour se voir.
Côté processeur on a un 10mm octa-core,
on a vraiment une machine performante.
Elle répond extrêmement bien.
On peut faire pleins de choses très rapidement.
C'est un produit qui est à mon avis de bonne
qualité.
On retrouve vraiment les caractéristiques
du Galaxy S8 en plus grand avec un petit peu
plus de mémoire.
Par contre en terme de prise en main et de
qualité d'écran ce format 6,3 pouces est
vraiment très agréable.
C'est un produit qui a 6Go de RAM.
Côté batterie on a une 3300 mAh.
On sait que la batterie c'est ce qui avait
causé un vrai fiasco pour le Galaxy Note
7.
Normalement ce Galaxy Note 8 avec un batterie
de 3300 mAh ne devrait pas avoir de problème.
La crainte que l'on peut avoir c'est que la
batterie soit trop légère par rapport à
la consommation de l'écran et par rapport
à l'utilisation de ce produit.
Mais je pense que l'on a pas à s'inquiéter
parce que Samsung a vraiment optimisé le
produit pour ne pas consommer énormément.
Normalement avec une batterie de 3300 mAh
ça devrait faire le job.
Bien évidemment on retrouve de l'USB-C mais
c'est un produit que l'on recherche par induction.
Ce qui fait que vous avez une recharge rapide,
quelque chose de très pratique.
C'est un produit pour résumer qui à mon
sens se tient bien.
Un écran très agréable.
L'écran Infinity c'est vraiment très sympa.
Points négatifs : la caméra de face qui
n'est pas assez performante et le déverrouillage
au dos.
Vous mettez votre doigt n'importe où.
Ce sont un peu les soucis de ce produits sinon
il est très sympa.
Dites-moi ce que vous en pensez en commentaire.
Pour ma part je trouve que c'est un bon produit.
Si vous cherchez un produit avec un stylet,
avec un grand écran, le Galaxy Note 8 fera
le job.
Mettez-moi tout ça en commentaire et on en
reparle très vite.
Salut.